okay so a bit of a fun video today I got
a question from one of my YouTube
viewers Muhammad who wrote in on the
video that I had about learning rock
music and he wrote in to say Evan I want
you to show me the difference between
salsa merengue bachata and kizomba so
Muhammad this is for you we're going to
go through the differences and how to
identify the music and then also do a
quick demo of what the dance looks like
this is Nina first one is merengue and
merengue you can identify it because it
is it's like dance music it's only got
to beat so it's boom boom boom boom boom
and as you're stepping it this is all
you have to do today it's Miranda you're
just stepping on the spot and so you can
hear the beats pretty clearly under
there
I'm going to put on an example
[Music]
so you can hear this song is beat beat
beat beat beat since that's merengue
okay and you just step in each time and
if you can walk you come around all the
moves end up just happen with the arms
but all you have to worry about is
stepping like this so if you hear it
kind of sounds like this dance music
that's ringing so do a quick demo what
that looks like
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
bring it pretty simple
next up we'll do pichai so with the
China it's a form read in summaries is
to beat and you're sucking every beat
but Java is a for beat Danes and the
weight identified is it's got a lot of
twenty Nastase a lector Qatar is
electric guitar guitar like a 20 guitar
sounding song it's a Dominican Republic
how's the the oranges from Dominican
Republic um let's we'll put on a song so
listen to the guitar pointyness if that
comes on you know it's for Charlie you
hear the guitar quite a guitar you know
25 of those guys down
[Music]
which at the other thing in bachata the
singers always like to save their names
so the artists so you have Prince Royce
who's a famous botrytis on in every
Prince Royce song he's going to say
Royce somewhere in there it's a thing of
a chatter for some reason they always
have to say their names and all the sons
at some point so if you hear them
calling out their own name
you know each other so we're making our
way up next one is salsa salsa is more
complicated
it's a 8 bit dance there's a whole bunch
of different origins and routes to it
how to tell the difference the main
instrument is a clapping it's a
percussion instrument that you can
sometimes hear a lot of the songs it's
but ba ba ba ba but a good way identify
these simply through the horn so if you
hear a lot of trumpets blasting you know
that's a salsa song versus something
else versus the guitar that you're going
to find a bachata versus like the
dancing music in and get you merengue
the a lot of the traditional salsa stuff
is also pretty upbeat up tempo makes you
feel happy so we're going to put on an
example for the trumpets
upbeat whatever looks like
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
salsa so the last one we're going to
cover is kizomba now in the in the video
the person at kizomba is that you could
kizomba and this is that it's an african
dance and it's the weakest of the four
that we're going to demo in terms of
what I know my skills is pretty limited
on kizomba but the biggest trademark
identify kizomba song is typically a
really heavy bass so you have this bass
it just keeps kicking in I'm going to
find an example for you we're gonna play
Unisphere he's almost song what's your
favorite I like it too so listen for the
bass okay listen to it
not yet not yet
here we go the hectic pace a little bit
off time zone
[Music]
like me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's on button so that's it quick intro
to what do we do
merengue bachata and salsa kizomba let
me know what you guys think you have
questions even below
you want me to demo something else let
me know maybe we'll make another video
for you and boys movies like this
subscribe to the channel in the corner
click on my face thanks guys and we'll
see you soon